hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game where you will have to pause
the video quite a lot it was played some
ten days ago in the Abu Dhabi Masters
this is Round four bahador Obama versus
Alexander English and it's uh well it's
really an interesting him all of the
games were very interesting and I really
had to decide which one to choose and
well for those who don't know sometimes
during 2012 Jabbar was irate at sound
2730 something which I believe in 2012
was enough to rate you maybe even in the
top 20 in the world and now he's reading
plummeted to 2050 80s so that's a
significant drop and well we haven't
heard from him in quite a while so just
checking up on how he's doing and this
is one of the games that I thought was
very interesting so without further ado
let's check it out and it also features
a very nice line of the Sicilian with
efore by Joe Baba
we have c5 by English nice to see 3
preparing the chameleon with nigt 2 we
have Knight to c6 and now Knight G to e2
the chameleon variation which is which
can often be used as a surprise to your
opponents as it's somewhat unexplored so
you know maybe black can wander off in
some uncharted territory
we have g6 by black and now Jabbar just
transposes in 3rd the accelerator dragon
with b 4c captures Knight captures and
now Bishop to g7 with Bishop to b3 Java
declines the trade gets the night over
to b3 and now Knight to f6 black
prepares the castle
we have Bishop to e2 and now d6 and here
both players Castle we have castles
castles sorted castles castles and and
now look T 1 we have b6 by black
preparing Bishop to b7 and pal Bishop to
g5 and Bishop to b7 we have Queen to d2
preparing in Bishop to e6 the trade of
the dark square Bishop and now rook the
c8 and there is one game in the database
for Bishop to f1 was played but here
Bishop h6 is a new move and now as a
move 12 we have a completely new game
and I almost forgot always just get this
over with
all right that's very nice
we have 95 now just putting the Knights
to a nice central square also eyeing
that c4 square
Knight to c4 would be a very nice move
so here Java just prevents it will
worship Catherine g7 Queen capture some
sort of kink actress on g7 and now Queen
to d4 and I centralizing move with the
Queen also not the bishop and the queen
guard the c-4 square and if you don't
want the Queen to remain on such a
lovely central a centralized square you
have to get rid of her so Knight back to
c6 pushing the Queen back with Quinta
III and now with a six by black we have
rook a to d1 nicely developing and now
Queen to e7 black also develops connects
the rooks and now the other row can come
for example to da torre eight we have
Queen to c1 now this is a an excellent
attacking move by Jabara you might be
wondering what kind of an attacking a
movie screen 2 c1
well it just clears the e3 square for
the white rook
the idea is rugby 3 followed by root 2 H
3 and from H 3 both the rook and the
Queen are controlling the age six
squares so this is what Obama will use
as an attacking idea we have rook F to
d8 now preparing d5 and here rook to d3
just continuing with his idea with bush
up to a six now with idea of maybe
training of the lights for bishops rook
to h3 as planned Bishop captures an e -
and now rook captures an D - yo Baba
doesn't like quint h6 check first
as the h7 point is protected so after
King g8 you will have to recapture then
Queen f8 and the White Queen has to go
back you're not really interested in
trading Queens here so just look at Reza
Ani - and now Inge plays h5 preventing
any Queen to h6 ideas we have f4 by Jo
bhava and now comes Knight to g4 so the
knight is now nicely protected on g4 and
well you could have some ideas of maybe
pushing d5 then you if the knight ever
moves from b3 you could have some Queen
c5 check maybe followed by Knight to f2
so look the f3
putting the roof to a new attacking
square and now also two rooks guard ef-2
square so you know you always have less
the cocktail
in the future with a six by black and
now h3 kicking the night back Knight to
f6 and now comes Queen to e one the
queen is now coming to f2 with b5 by
black now this Queen this diagonal opens
up for the black queen so white just
gets the King got away with King to h1
and now comes Luke the c7 and here we
have Queen to f2 and here
black black should have taken this
opportunity to play b4 and just bust
open with d5 for example before you get
rid of the knight defending the d5
square Knight a 4 and now b5 and this
would have been great for black for
exactly captures rook captures and the
position nicely opens up and as we
always say if you can push d5 as black
and the Sicilian you should always do it
if you can here black played rook to e8
first preparing a5 now
and here's abhava realized that there
was a grave danger lurking with this b4
move so he just prevented it with a
three we have rook to a treat now
preparing h4 and here chavalla plays
rook back to d3 with h4 and now rookie
to d2 piling up on the d6 pawn with a 5
here preparing to push a 4 B 4 depending
on what white plays Queen to III and the
now comes a 4 and here Jabba doesn't
mind old upon pushing on the Queen side
he plays knife to d4 and here you have
to capture the night and night capture
some before after rook captures you can
play rook aged back to c8 and you
continue the game in this fashion but
here in display nights the a5 and here
at Joe bhava played a very nice idea
with b3 now challenging the pawn here a
cat person b3c capture son b3 and now
rook the b7 preparing a trick trick as
the b5 point is attacked twice you don't
really have a good way of defending it
but this is what I meant when I said you
Baba doesn't mind all the pawn pushing
on the Queen side here
Knight C captures on b5 is played and E
5 now as black prepared a 5 so his idea
is that of course after F captures an e5
and D captures and in fact now you have
to move the knight and after the knight
moves you just nicely win a piece
but the Obama had something else in mind
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find what your Baba had in mind
here while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent Forker of kings and queens and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show Knight f5 and yes now the b5
point is under unprotected but your king
is in check and also the queen is under
attack so you do have to capture the
night if you don't want to lose the
Queen here with F capture sorry G
captors on f5 Queen g5 check and now
what do you do do you go King f8 or kink
to h7 Gabala had to do a lot of
calculating here because for example if
King to h7 then you get Knight to d6
first you get the knight into the game
and it doesn't really matter what black
plays the f5 point is under attack
the h4 pony is under attack the rukon b7
is under attack so whatever you do here
let's say Ruby g8 you're gonna get Queen
it captures on h4 check King g7 and now
just Knight captures on f5 another check
where you will lose the Queen on the
other hand after Knight to d6 you might
try something like Knight stop
eh-oh for a queen trade but then Queen
captures on a5 check King h6 now Knight
captures on b7 you just win material
Knight captures on b7 and now rook to d7
wins the more material the queen and the
night are under attack if Queen f6 just
captures here and well you will just
enjoy a much better endgame so kink the
h7 out of the question in gg-ghost king
to f8 but Obama has everything planned
out with rook to d8 with check and now
Knight stay it or you can just grab the
rook and then you lose the game but
after night we ate you still have to
find what to play here so again feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the winning move for J Bhabha
in this situation while I give you a
couple of seconds for those who were
able to do it congratulations for
solving yet another puzzle in this very
exciting game and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
rook captures on e8 this is the idea and
now whatever black plays is insufficient
for example if King captures then you
get Queen to Jesus
seven threatening Queen captures rook as
the rook controls the D file and after
rook to f8 you're just gonna get the
Knight to d6 check tink the d8 and now
you play Knight captures on f5
discovering a check and now the queen is
under attack you have to play King e8 if
you don't want to lose the rook as well
so king of King yet Knight captures rook
sorry characters for example and now you
have yes black does have two rooks for a
queen but you also have a look against
the night and white will be completely
winning here so after rook captures any
eight-inch play the Queen captures any
eight and now you could play rook the
eighth although it doesn't give you all
that much black will play rook captures
and b5 and now after you capture the
Queen captures captures you still have
to play against two rooks and the night
okay here white is tactically winning
because after Queen f6 attacking the
rook you have to move it and then B 4 is
just deadly as you either lose the
knight or remove the night and then you
face queen c6 check but it's a lot of
unnecessary [ __ ] calculation because
there is a much better move after Queen
captures on e8 not rook the d8 right
away but first Queen to f6 and now it's
a bit different and you shall see why
it's different Rock the g8 by image and
the now comes rook to DA so you might
think okay it's the same line but it's
not rook captures on b5 just grabbing
the night and now okay you could capture
here push b4 like we had in that line
but there is a much better move so for a
third and last time in this video pause
it and find the absolute best move for
white which is what zubaba played while
i give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
solver of all the positions that I asked
you to solve in this video and for those
of you who just won't enjoy the show
Queen to h6 check and now you see the
problem if you move the king then Queen
to d6 is mate we again have this
structure where the king has nowhere to
go and the Queen just controls this
diagonal and if you play rook to g7
after Queen to h6 well this was played
or rook to g7 just blocking check now
you get Queen d6 check and now the King
has to move the Queen cannot block as
the Queen is
so you have to move the King King g8
rook captures an e8 with check King to
h7 and now just Queen to d7 and it was
in this position that Alexander English
resigned the game and an excellent
victory for bodily Java in round four of
the Abu Dhabi Masters 2019 so why did he
resign well aside from the obvious
material difference his rook is under
attack also the f5 pawn is under attack
if you play Ruby 6 to maybe get to the
rook into the game now you play Queen d8
attack the rook and the h4 pawn again
and now after Luke h6 defending the pawn
now play captures on f5 you take away
the g6 Square from the black King
threatening Rock h8 mate and after a
black deals with this now you just go
for some rock hunting rookie Jade check
in just serve and you deliver check
working here check King captures and mal
after a few more moves a black will get
checkmate it and that is it so of course
I both do bhava in English nudists and
here in g2 resign the game so this is
not the only game Jabba ones your bubble
on all the games he played accepted that
he drew but he didn't lose any of the
games and he won the Abu Dhabi Masters
2019 which is well a big achievement for
him in a very long time which is usually
the case his games are always
interesting as he plays a very
aggressive style very attacking style
such as I mean like McHale towel for
example and well with that style you
don't very often have the adequate
results he will play some very
interesting games certain fries a lot of
pieces play brilliantly but then maybe
he will finish 3rd or 10th and maybe
even lose rating but here he won seven
games drew two and he finished clear
first and he would want some
30-something rating points so he he
jumped from 2025 eighty 226 something so
obviously getting getting the rating
back now but it's usually the case when
someone plays a very interesting style
they will they will not get all that
much result but they will play
very very interesting games and people
will be very happy when they see their
games you know such as for example or
our shinojima dinos games but yeah here
I would just like to share the standings
here are the standings after nine rounds
of the Abu Dhabi Masters you can see but
dual Joe Baba sorry it's bigger like
that but George Obama first with eight
points eight out of nine that's just
just insane second another back with
twenty sorry with seven points and then
were all the rest with six and a half
six and five which is just a well
basically crushing the field yeah
there we have it I do hope you enjoyed
it I I certainly have I would like to
thank Lionel byte on our Tom Stefan high
school again the 11 and levan serve and
Eric Cryer for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see soon checking up
on your suggestions we're starting with
the single Cup today and of course
continuing the Capablanca saga so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend